une fort quand même que l'union
européenne se trouve au se positionne un
patient ce producteur de canards le sait
l'autorisation de vacciner doit venir de
bruxelles christophe barrailh se dit
prête à immuniser ses 3000 bêtes mais
ils souhaitent en savoir plus sur les
aides de l'état
reste à définir les modalités
d'accompagnement des producteurs parce
qu'effectivement cette démarche en coûte
il ya un besoin d'organisation il ya une
nécessité de financer de la main
d'oeuvre
en cas de feu vert de l'union européenne
neuf cent mille oies et canards seront
vaccinés 2000 élevage proches des zones
humides de trois départements seront
concernés landes loire atlantique et
vendée
les modalités ce spécialiste d'un
fabricant américain du vaccin est venue
des exposés dans les landes très
résistant au h5n1
c'est palmipèdes peuvent véhiculer le
virus en tant que porteur ça alors
pourquoi cibler uniquement aux oies et
canards
la réponse est ça pour éviter que ces
canards qui sont moins sensibles que les
autres oiseaux au virus influenza
deviennent des porteurs suite à une
contamination par des oiseaux sauvages
la vaccination va prévenir à si la
contamination des élevages environnants
autre question quel sera le nombre
d'injections nécessaire une seule
devrait produire ses effets pendant
cette semaine a expliqué ce responsable
de laboratoire à des vétérinaires
landais mais il y aura sans doute un
rappel pour être totalement efficace une
primo vaccination un jour et un rappel à
trois semaines vont permettre une
installation limité très précoce puisque
on vaccine d un jour et un maintien dans
le temps de l'unité
dernière inconnue les premières
vaccinations pourront elles avoir lieu
dès mercredi selon la direction des
services vétérinaires des landes
un tel scénario est tout à fait possible
l'affront